people here are still in shock the
explosion that shook the entire
neighborhood around the depot muhammad
rithwan is just one of the people who
were badly injured
we were observing the fire near the deep
gate and then in a blink of an eye there
was a major explosion then suddenly
flaming metal debris hit me on my head
as i was running to seek shelter in a
shop
authorities are still searching for the
cause of the fire
what we have initially learned from the
explosion is that this happened due to a
leak of hydrogen peroxide and it is what
likely created the spark
charities are helping victims and their
families
we've provided ambulance services to
those who were injured or died from the
fire incident and alongside that we're
also providing emergency medicine food
and clothes to those who are affected
although firefighters managed to bring
the deadly blaze under control the
containers are still smoldering
clearance and salvage operation is still
going on you can see the level of
devastation i can smell fume there's
chemicals on the ground journalists were
only given few minutes to check out the
premises and then we were told to leave
this area because there is clearly more
danger around
victims families crowd the corridors of
the hospital
my nephew was a truck driver who came to
drop goods at the container depot that
night but he never got the chance to
unload the goods and instead got
severely injured due to the explosion
the owners of the container depot said
they will help the victims
our main goal is to help those who are
injured and help the families of the
dead on an urgent basis and the company
will help the victims families for the
rest of their lives and even bear the
children's education expense
many of the containers contain
internationally recognized cloth brands
and while safety standards have improved
in factories in recent years experts say
more needs to be done across the entire
supply chain tanvi chaudhary al jazeera
sita condo bangladesh